Speaker 1: So today we start with last night's
election results, which are I mean, I'll skip
to the conclusion they're an absolute disaster
for Democrats. They could spell major trouble
for the Democrats and for the left, to the extent
that the left exists in the United States through
the Democratic Party, that's an issue we can talk
about as well. There are a range of opinions about
how much of a disaster last night's results are,
and that's fine. But it's not good. It's not good.
The big race, the major race that so many were
looking at was the Virginia gubernatorial race,
where the Democratic governor, Ralph Northam,
who won by nine in 2017 in Virginia, was term
limited out. Two contenders were vying to replace
Ralph Northam. It was Democrat Terry McAuliffe
and Republican Glenn Youngkin. Now, the polls
were very tight over the last three weeks, I
continued saying it's basically even could be plus
one or two in either direction. Terry McAuliffe,
a completely milquetoast Democrat not particularly
inspiring in any way. Not particularly distressing
in any way other than sort of like distressing
in the sense of is this guy really going to
inspire people to turn out and vote? Glenn
Youngkin, on the other hand, a truly disgusting,
radical Republican playing up cultural issues as
expected and as Republicans have been doing over
the last many years and young one, young and one.
Now interestingly, you know, let's put aside for
a second. No Republicans are claiming fraud that
I'm aware of in any of these races from yesterday,
even though you had some Republicans saying
it looks like Democrats are stealing votes in
Virginia. And if McAuliffe wins, we'll probably
say there was fraud and now they're all silent.
I mean, we can't even deal with that today
because it's so absurd. But as the results went,
as the results came in early in the night last
night, Glenn Youngkin got up to even a 10,
10 and a half point lead. I think at one point,
as the more left leaning counties with large
populations were counted, the lead tightened and
tightened. But it ended up being a roughly two
point win in Virginia for the Republican. Glenn
Youngkin Now the scary part, the question we were
talking about yesterday, including on our live
stream with many of our viewers from Virginia,
and it's been written about extensively
in the first few hours of today by all of
the typical political voices. Is the Virginia
gubernatorial election a bellwether for 2022?
Some say yes. Definitely. This spells disaster for
Democrats in 2022. Others say no. Some say, well,
maybe somewhat, but not totally. What there is
no way to deny is that bellwether aside for 2022,
when the last race for Virginia governor was won
by nine by a Democrat, and now it's one by two
by a Republican. That's an 11 point swing in one
cycle. That's not good for Democrats in Virginia,
period. Now in a moment, we'll look at the
historical. It's not uncommon that in Virginia,
the governor's race goes the opposite way that
the White House went in the previous election.
That's not uncommon, but it still doesn't bode
well for 2022, even if you concede that it's a
historical pattern. So we're going to talk about
that. Virginia was a state that we were hoping
was leaning more and more left, and Republicans
won it. Republicans won it and they won it with
a really simple tactic. And this is important
to understand. Democrats are not very good at
messaging, it's almost cliche to say it, we've
done so many interviews about it. We've talked to
Thomas Frank about it, we've talked to George
Lakoff. We've talked about it in so many different
ways. Democrats are not very good at messaging in
particular. Republicans know the messaging that
will get people to vote and that will get people
to vote for them. It doesn't matter if it's based.
In fact, it doesn't matter if it's totally wrong.
They understand Republicans that if they get
their base angry enough and scared enough, it will
motivate their voters to go to the polls. There is
just no way. And I hate that. I mean, this is not
even a political thing. This is almost psychology
sociology. There is no way that Democrats can
get the same amount of motivation and energy
to get their base to turn out by pitching
green energy, equal equality of opportunity
and all these things that actually matter compared
to how Republicans do it with fear and with
anger. And Republicans did it in Virginia with
talk of fixing education and getting rid of
critical race theory. The very same Republicans
think about the absurdity from a value standpoint,
the same Republicans who claim that as a value,
they don't want government doing too much. They
want to limit the areas that government is even
involved. They got people angry and afraid enough
to go out and vote by saying, We're going to get
in there and tell schools what to teach. That was
a big part of Glenn Youngins campaign and the
people around Youngkin interviews with voters.
Republican voters in Virginia showed they were
voting young and many of them because they wanted
him to deal with education and critical race
theory. It's absurd, it's absurd, and it's counter
to their stated values. But it worked, and they
won the race. Then we had the gubernatorial race
in New Jersey. Now it was believed to be a very
safe seat for the incumbent Democratic Gov. Phil
Murphy in the blue state of New Jersey, where Joe
Biden defeated Donald Trump easily in 2022. By 16,
Biden beat Trump by 16 and Jersey in 2020. And
Phil Murphy did jump out to a big lead up front.
But then, as the night went on and
we watched the results come in,
the Republican challenger gained and gained
and eventually took a two point lead. Now,
as more votes came in overnight as I just looked
at it and hopefully this is not outdated by the
time you listen to today's show. But as of just
15 minutes ago, the race has not been called.
And with 92 percent reporting, Phil Murphy is
back in the lead, but by 0.06 percent. That's not
0.6 percent. It's zero point zero six percent,
about 3400 votes. Eight percent of the ballots
still to be counted. Now, if Democrats lose the
New Jersey governorship, it's a disaster. Even
if Murphy wins, but by less than not even less
than a point, less than a tenth of a point, it is
what the margin is right now to massive swing in
2017. Phil Murphy won by 15 points in New Jersey,
then Biden won easily in 2020. And now Phil Murphy
is trying to eke out a win by a tenth of a point
as of 15 minutes ago. So no matter who wins.
Republicans closed a massive gap in a very, very
blue state. That also doesn't bode well if you
were of the mindset. Well, Virginia doesn't tell
us much by itself. Well, it's not by itself. Look
at Virginia and New Jersey. And then what else
we're going to talk about more of the results on
the bonus show today. Some of the results are very
much expected. Democrat Eric Adams won New York
City mayor, a left leaning candidate. Michelle Wu,
one Boston mayor. And then, you know, not
surprisingly, self-described socialist India.
Walton did not win the Buffalo mayorship lost by
a lot by 17 points to a write-in candidate. I know
that many progressives were very interested in
that race. It is not super shocking to me that
a self-described socialist did not get elected
mayor of Buffalo, New York. Joe Biden won buffalo
easily, but Democratic voters are not necessarily
socialist voters. And that's not shocking
there, and we'll look at some of the other
results on the bonus show today. Now I do
think it's important to restate. That in a lot of
ways, this was a turn out victory for Republicans.
There were anecdotally Republicans saying, My
Democratic friends are voting for Republicans this
time around in Jersey, in Virginia, in some other
races. And anecdotally, there are always examples
of everything some Republicans who vote Democrat.
Democrats who vote Republican, etc, but really,
it was using fear and anger to get turnout. For
example, Terry McAuliffe actually outperformed
Joe Biden among some groups. Sahil Kapoor from
NBC News pointed this out in a tweet and said,
You know, among white women college graduates,
Biden got 58 percent of that group in 2020,
whereas Terry McAuliffe got 62 percent of
that group in 2020. McAuliffe built the lead
that Joe Biden had among white women with college
degrees. But it just wasn't enough because other
groups did not turn out in the numbers that Terry
McAuliffe needed. So non-college educated white
women voted for Youngkin by an even bigger
margin than they voted for Donald Trump. So
what we had was an exaggeration of the 2020
results, with the turnout favoring Republicans.
Now, does that mean 2022 looks less bad? Not
really. This could point to a very bad 2022
because midterms are often turnout elections. So
Democrats need to number one, do some stuff now.
But I mean, that sounds silly. They need to get
some things done that they can point to and say,
Hey, look at these things that we actually did.
You've you've got to do some things and we're
going to talk about spending an infrastructure
bill a little bit later. But saying that Terry
McAuliffe simply ran a bad campaign is myopic.
New Jersey shouldn't be this close. Pennsylvania
Supreme Court won by Republicans if Democrats
don't want to accept this as a wake up call
publicly to save face. OK. I mean, you know,
there's debate. Do you ever really admit that
it was a disaster for you? Maybe you don't.
But privately, Democrats had better see this
as a wake up call. And it's almost more difficult
without Trump on the ballot. As I've said before,
it's harder to say, even though we haven't done
much, vote for us anyway. When Trump's not there,
when it's Trump, when it's overtly a referendum
on Trump, the we aren't Trump message makes more
sense because Trump is such a train wreck, even
if you don't have that much that you've done to
point to. You're not Trump. You're not crazy
in that way. When there's no Trump, it's well,
we're better than these other Republicans who also
aren't Trump. It's weak in terms of messaging.
It's weak in terms of framing. And there's a
very good article in The Atlantic this morning
by Elaine Godfrey and Russell Berman called If
Democrats can lose Virginia, they can lose almost
anywhere, which points out that Youngkin neither
repudiated nor Embiid embraced Trump. He really
didn't do either. He actually kind of played coy
with Trump, and we talked about this all along,
and Republicans ended up winning that race. Now,
let let me now after everything I've said about
how disastrous this could be. Let me just present
to you the least disastrous interpretation. Just
so you know that there is one, and it would be the
following. It's really common that in Virginia,
the governorship goes to the opposition party
when there is a new president. So when Carter won
in the next election, Virginia Governor
Gubernatorial went to Republicans when Reagan
won it, then went to Democrats when Bush senior
won it, then went to Democrats. When Clinton won,
it switched to Republicans. When George W. Bush
won it, switched to Democrat. When Obama won,
switched to Republicans. And now. And same
with Trump. Switched to Democrats. And now
we have Biden wins and it switches to
Republican. So if you want to point
to that and say that's how Virginia works,
it's not really a big concern. You can find
a justification in the history to make that claim.
But with the New Jersey numbers not looking good
and with some of these other things not looking
good, I certainly wouldn't be taking that chance.
And it's a completely plausible scenario.
Can't yet say likely lot of things need
to happen where we've got a year until the 2020
midterms, which I think are really going to get
going in late February, early March. It could
be an absolute bloodbath for Democrats in 2022
if Biden then does not run for reelection,
which is plausible. And then you've got,
you know, like a not super popular, popular Kamala
Harris as the nominee. There could be a scenario,
and I always want to balance being realistic, but
not being alarmist, but not downplaying things,
we could have a scenario where 2022 is a disaster.
For Democrats, 2024 is a disaster for Democrats,
and you end up with Democrats trying to take
control back of something in 2026, after
Republicans have gotten a lot of opportunity to do
some serious damage to this country, damage that
will take, you know, to 2030 to start undoing. I
mean, it's a it's a grim and dark potential path.
And that's why it's important to see every single
one of these elections in context. So let me know
your thoughts. Let me know your interpretation.
We're going to have more on some of the minor
races on today's bonus show, which you can
get access to by becoming a member at Join
Packman dot com and you can find me on Twitter at
David Pakman and let me know your interpretation,
your analysis of yesterday's election results.
All right, welcome back, everybody. Remember,
we do depend on your support to run our program to
fund all of the things we do pay salaries, pay for
equipment, pay for connectivity, pay for benefits
for employees, which I always want to be a good
employer and providing. You can grab a membership
at join Packman dot com. You can use the coupon
code felony 21 to get a discount. It's a big
discount. It's a very big discount and you'll get
access to The Daily Bonus Show as a member.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.